[Music]
because I think I want to show you off
and I want to make you happy
so you see basically I'm still the same
selfish screws I've always been oh don't
ever say that you wonderful that is Eric
Braeden back in 1981 on the CBS soap
opera The Young and the Restless the
emmy-winning actor has been 37 years
playing self-made businessman Victor
Newman on the long-running show now
Braden has a new memoir it's called I'll
be damned if you watch the show you know
he says that a lot how my young and
restless life led me to America's number
one daytime drama we are pleased to
welcome Eric Braeden to the table or
shall we call you selfish Scrooge
which would you prefer this morning Eric
brave okay Ari so nice to be here it's
so nice to have you here do you know Rob
yeah I really think you should give a
shout-out to your wife Dale because you
weren't even going to resign on young
and restless and she convinced you to
say after one season you were done she
said nope you should do this she
encouraged me from early on in this very
tough business of Hollywood show
business yeah oh and always encouraged
and she did indeed encouraged me to sign
for the next many years - ah yeah 1576
episodes till you 2507 are you serious
little Anthony never lost shame but why
didn't you want to re-sign
what was it I didn't like the medium of
soaps because you have to learn too much
Dino yeah yeah yeah we do I learn
between 10 and the most I've ever done
in one day was 62 pages of dialogue yeah
yeah yeah and that becomes overwhelming
yeah and then you have to act at the
same time so by now I find it to be a
challenge have made it a challenge and
have enjoyed it ever since but she's the
one who suggested that I look at it as a
channel yeah she saved you many times I
think you're doing
no I first encountered you as I said
when you came on the set of my fandom of
yours precedes young and the rest
because you were when I was a kid you
were on a show called the Rat Patrol in
1966 I would have been 10 we watched it
every week you're going to put my
friends and I I was 12
yes look early and you went by you
played the Nazi commander in North
Africa and you went by a different name
you went on eschew Riga hands good again
good captain d3 and the Rat Patrol yes
let's go to that which is your real name
that's my real theory exactly but you
and you ended up changing it because the
only parts they wanted to give you were
Nazi parts basically no that isn't the
reason Lew Wasserman they tested me at
Universal Studios yeah for the lead in
the picture called Colossus the foreman
project yeah science fiction film and a
very good one and they decided they
wanted me but then said no one with the
German name worst on an American picture
yeah really you were told you would have
been a big store if you hadn't been a
German act yeah and that happened at a
certain party after a few drinks and
finally said that so you took the advice
and change your name the advice how did
you come over the Arab Spring how did
you cope with that Braden is from the
first part of the village I'm from a
Germany called bleeding me you know
what's interesting is your German
background in which you talk very
candidly about that your dad was a
member of the Nazi Party and one of the
things you that bothers you is how
people think anybody from Germany was a
Nazi and you made a point you called it
an intellectual odyssey to learn
everything you can about that era it is
the most baffling baffling phenomenon to
wrap your head around read countless
things interview countless people
including family members and it's a
12-year period in German history and
when you ask most Americans about
Germany there's an immediate transition
to that 12-year period in German history
to the exclusion of everything else
you're not minimizing that period but
you're saying losing or other things
kind of possibly minimize
we should learn lessons from that right
but Germans are the largest ethnic group
in America yeah that's right
that is unbeknownst in most people yeah
the contributions of German immigrants
in this country been enormous
fundamental substantial eric braeden
thank you so much for being with us the
book you I'll be damned
is on sale now